[Musique]
bonjour david dufresne bonjour bonjour
pour nous dans les studios de france 24
qu'il est et 8 heures et 14 minutes
mais pour vos lecteurs pour le monde
dans lequel nous allons plonger ce matin
il est
19h59 c'est le titre de votre second
roman il se situe dans le sillage d'un
autre livre dernière sommation que se
passe-t-il à 19h59
19h59 qui se passe ce qui arrive tous
les maintenant cinq ans en france c'est
à dire c'est le moment où les chaînes
d'information ont encore quelques
secondes avant de donner le résultat de
l'élection présidentielle
c'est un compte à rebours comme il y en
a plein dans son studio new line al
ayyam un là
mais en réalité c'est un compte à
rebours qui racontent le monde dans
lequel nous sommes c'est à dire
justement un monde profondément
médiatique profondément spectaculaire
donc en réalité c'est pas tant le
résultat de l'élection présidentielle
qui importe que comment on en arrive à
faire en sorte que tel candidat s'en
sortent ou pas vous êtes journaliste
documentariste vous connaissez bien la
télévision ou vous même avez été
directeur en chef d'une chaîne d'info
continue on va y revenir alors votre
livre on mène effectivement au coeur
d'un monde politique médiatique
policiers tout cela mélangé on y
retrouve une galerie de personnages dont
emmanuel macron est un milliardaire
propriétaire d'une chaîne d'information
continue cela s'appelle rex news vous
connaissez la fameuse formule toute
ressemblance avec des personnes ou des
situations réelles ou ayant existé n'est
que fortuite mais là vous prenez david
dufresne assez peu de précautions parce
que finalement nous sommes dans le réel
que vous dites vouloir pétrir oui si ça
c'est alors pétrir d'une autre d'une
autre manière que de la manière
journalistique à journalistes qui
auraient fait une enquête aurait dit les
vraies non c'est pas tellement les vrais
noms qui m'intéresse mais les logiques
qui sont à l'oeuvre et la littérature ce
qu'elle a dit d'intéressant de mon point
de vue c'est non pas quand elle relate
seulement le réel mais quand elle ne
devance un peu et c'est pour ça que
j'utilise quelques subterfuges
littéraire on va dire donc effectivement
on comprend bien qu'ils se philippe rex
qui est un milliardaire qui possède une
chaîne d'information qui s'appelle rex
news qui avança avait un autre nom et
cette chaîne il y as matin midi et soir
l'extrême droite qui à table ouverte
donc on voit à peu près de 2 qu'il
s'agit mais c'est pas de qui il s'agit
qui m'importe c'est les logiques c'est
ce que ça signifie ce que ça nous
annonce pour les années qui viennent
parce qu'évidemment ça parle pas de 2022
ça parle du monde dans lequel on est
aujourd'hui pour je pense un certain
nombre d'années et pour qu'on comprenne
un peu mieux l'histoire
19h59 c'est un roman nous sommes dans
l'entre-deux tours de l'élection
présidentielle le survivalistes qui
revient d'ukraine du dombass plus
exactement kidnappe un milliardaire
propriétaire de ce fameux ou de cette
fameuse chaîne fox news il exige un
débat à la télévision directe avec
emmanuel macron et là on plonge dans un
monde de folie absolue de quarks news
est il le nom
est un mélange de spectaculaire où tout
est bon pour le spectacle avec une
immense animant cynisme une grande
grande paresse intellectuelle
et tout ça fait de l'audience
tout ça a fait de la réplique fait de la
rhétorique fait ce que j'appelle du
commissariat c'est à dire que alors ça
c'est effectivement un regard que je
porte parce qu'il ya une vingtaine
d'années vous l'avez dit j'ai été
rédacteur en chef d'une chaîne
d'information et ses terres j'ai bien vu
le glissement tout le monde le voit
alors évidemment ici je suis mal placé
pour le dire parce que vous êtes le
contre-exemple parfait est la limite
vous est le contre-exemple des autres
chaînes d'information dont on voit bien
qu'elles sont avant tout des chaînes de
fabrication de l'opinion et d'une
certaine manière moi ça ne me dérange
pas ce qui me dérange c'est qu'elles ne
veulent pas le reconnaître elle dit
jamais non pas du tout nous ont fait de
l'info etc c'est pas vrai elle fabrique
une opinion c'est leur droit elle
elles répondent à des logiques c'est
leur droit mais c'est aussi mon droit de
romanciers de dire attendez là il ya
tromperie sur la marchandise et donc
c'est de ça et c'est quoi en gros c'est
ce qu'on a eus aux états unis avec fox
news je prends juste deux secondes on
sait que fox news il ya des études
scientifiques pour le coup qui ont
démontré que partout où foxnews avait un
taux de pénétration important le vote
trup était important tout récemment le
courrier international a traduit un
article de recherche aux états unis où
on a mis des téléspectateurs de fox news
devant cnn en un mois il avait changé
d'avis donc on est clair face quand on
considère rex news qui est une fiction
mais évidemment et sans se mentir on
voit de quelle chaîne vous parlez on est
dans cette fabrique du commentaire et
donc de l'opinion mais pas n'importe
laquelle finalement d'une certaine
opinion puisque ça va vers ce tout ce
qu'il ya de plus extrême dans cette
société même fictive bien sûr bien sûr
donc là c'est au service de l'extrême
droite mais là dessus si c'est
extrêmement clair
historiquement il faudra quand même
qu'on retienne que lors du premier tour
2022 33 % des gens qui ont voté pas des
français mais des gens qui ont voté ont
voté que sam droite marine le pen eric
zemmour niveau nicolas dupont aignan 33%
ça ça vient pas de nulle part si vous
voulez ça vient en partie d'une
fabrication de deux priorités qui sont
donnés dans par des chaînes sur tel ou
tel sujet qui avec tel ou tel bi etc
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que le
roman il est à la fois sûr et rex news
mais il est aussi et surtout sur
l'imbrication du politique et du
médiatique est ce que c'est ça que vous
appelez
la bataille culturelle dans la société
française alors c'est ce que gramsci
avait avait écrit
donc c'était ce penseur communiste voilà
antonio gramsci qui a été récupérée
précisément par l'extrême droite ça
c'est très intéressant à la fin des
années soixante dix il ya des
intellectuels d'extrême droite qui ont
dit oh la la ce garçon là a dit quelque
chose d'important s'est il faut mener la
bataille de l'opinion la bataille de
l'eau une révolution quelle qu'elle soit
ne se gagne d'abord que par les esprits
et après par les armes et donc il faut
mener la bataille de alors la bataille
de l'image de l'opinion et c'est le vrai
terme c'est l hégémonie culturelle
c'était ça le terme de gramsci on est en
plein dedans et le roman tout modeste
soit-il il est il fait partie de cette
bataille si vous voulez c'est une sorte
pavé dans cette bataille est-ce que face
à cela la réponse de certaines personnes
de nombreuses personnes mais consiste à
dire qu'elle ne regarde pas la
télévision est ce que c'est pour vous
une bonne réponse reçue c'est la
meilleure réponse
c'est très intéressant ce que ce que
vous dites parce que j'ai comme beaucoup
de gens ici de comprendre pourquoi
marine le pen avait autant marché en
france lors de cette élection sans mener
campagne sauf avec des photos de chats
enfin
et en discutant avec des chercheurs en
discutant justement avec des
documentaristes titre qui travaillent en
discutant avec des gens qui
réfléchissent à ces questions là je me
suis rendu compte que la télévision
reste est un élément absolument majeur
et on a tendance une partie de la
population qui c'est qui a débranché sa
télévision parce qu'être s'est mise à
internet parce que lé plus nomades et
les plus mobiles que la télé c'est un
gros machin on a eu tendance à dire la
télé c'est fini non pas du tout la télé
ça reste central c'est capital donc il
n'y a plus cette consommation linéaire
la télévision dans le salon comme autant
de mais on consomme quand même la
télévision de deux mille et une manières
y compris par ses fameuses vidéos
19h59 david dufresne est ce que c'est un
livre politique
vous me faites des blancs là
alors est ce que c'est un livre
politique à ce que vous diriez que
positif est-ce que vous ne diriez alors
malheureusement moi qui fais le test est
pas la réponse mais finalement vu des
choses nous décrivez je dirais que c'est
un livre politique parce que le
personnage que vous
décrivez que vous mettez en scène
etienne dardel illustre personnage de
gauche il a l'air un peu quand même
déboussolés et nous nous sommes la vraie
vie non je crois alors un mot sur
l'avenir quand même fait qu'elle
projection vers le futur quand on a
compris tout cela vous fait partie de
david dufresne de ceux qui pensent qu'il
faut organiser le pessimisme expliquez
nous oui eh eh bien si la réponse à
votre question
la politique c'est la cité c'est la
gestion de la cité ce livre là
effectivement c'est c'est pas de la
littérature de salon donc je suis dans
une bataille qui est celle qu'on vient
de décrire et organiser le pessimisme
alors ça c'est justement un autre
penseur à peu près la même époque pierre
naville un surréaliste qui un jour a
écrit cette phrase qui moi m'a marqué et
quand j'ai découvert ça ya 30 ans à vie
il faut organiser le pessimisme
or c'est une phrase je l'entends comme
un appel à la halla halla halla à
l'action à la bataille
c'est pas du tout une phrase défaitiste
mais je crois qu'effectivement audois
qu'on doit tirer leçons les leçons de de
l'époque dans laquelle on est qui et je
veux dire qu'on soit de gauche ou de
droite on s'accorde tous pour dire que
là on est on est quand même désemparés
et pour cette bataille dans cette
bataille la littérature est essentielle
l'homme aime qu'on l'appelle la
littérature d'urgence
essentiel je sais pas mais utile
elle est la porte elle ouvre elle ouvre
des perspectives
elle ne faisait pas respectivement les
ailes et par an ferme et justement dans
le commentaire du commentaire de la
polémique elle elles tracent des lignes
de a observé à suivre merci beaucoup
d'avenir et à vous d'être venu jusqu'à
nos
19h59 romancier documentariste
journaliste s'est invitée de paille
direct merci de rester sur nos chaînes
d'informations internationales et
françaises continuent sur france 24
merci à vous